good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2022-2023
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series the seminar series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grants
from the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
differing themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where we will enjoy presentations on
Friday afternoons from leading thinkers
about the issues the promise
opportunities and hurdles associated
with understanding the secondary health
effects of the covid-19 virus these
include delayed Health checkups
treatments mental health drug abuse
policy implications other things such as
increased obesity and long lingering
health effects associated with the
covid-19 virus
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab will
leverage these presentations as vital
material for our culminating in-person
Grant project development and workshop
to be to be held at the lodge at St
Edwards Park in Seattle Washington in
June 2023. today we have a very special
presentation and I'm delighted to
welcome not one but Forest speakers
Julia Roper Autumn Lerner Darcy sawatski
and Jennifer Cho from the Panorama group
based in Seattle Washington
one of the uh of them Julia Roper is one
of our uh bdsil mentors this year we're
very excited to have her and she is a
senior program officer at Panorama
strategy a social impact consultancy
where she works with clients ranging
from biotech companies philanthropies
and multi-layer multi excuse me
multilateral agencies to advance their
health strategies and especially
pertaining to policy program design
advocacy and partnership she's worked
with the World Health Organization
UNICEF and many other uh Global programs
initiatives and institutions Autumn
Lerner is a pandemic Action Network
director of communication and
Partnerships and she's an accomplished
Global Communications leader having over
20 years of experience at the
intersection of social impact program
leadership cross-cultural management
integrated campaigns and Community
engagement and she has been involved in
in helping to deliver work across 30
different countries in an extremely
adapted building partners ships and
managing stakeholders and influencing
things across markets in various sectors
Darcy sawatski it was named a 2020 top
woman in public relations by the pr news
and Darcy has a 23-year 23 year record
track record of success in health
Communications public and private
Partnerships social marketing campaign
development and media relations
um and as vice president of Partnerships
Jennifer Cho leads panorama's
collaboration with philanthropists
philanthropic organizations and
strategic Partners on a variety of
diverse opportunities
um for impacting uh their work and the
work of others she has more than 20
years of experience in non-profit
development
um working with a variety of different
organizations and startup divisions from
places such as New York University and
various other organizations
um in continuing with this year's
2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar series theme today's lecture
from Team Panorama is after the research
using policy advocacy and philanthropy
as levers to address the consequences of
covet 19. the Panorama group is a
platform for social change their
community of multiple organizations
develop scalable solutions for some of
the world's most pressing challenges
today the team from Panorama will speak
about their work to alleviate secondary
health effects of covid-19 by mobilizing
networks of Partners shaping policies
and advocating for resources and systems
of change and the role that data science
plays in achieving those goals as always
we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via YouTube and if you're
watching on YouTube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected 2022-2023 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and
alumni are encouraged to submit any
questions they have via the chat session
the chat feature of their Zoom sessions
I will synthesize these questions and
ask them on your behalf during the last
10 minutes or so of the lecture and with
that welcome team Panorama we are super
excited to hear from you guys
hi Jack thanks for that introduction
um and hello everyone we are excited to
be here I'm going to kick us off and
then bring in my colleagues throughout
the next hour
um before we dive in in case you did not
pick up on this already from our bios
and want to get the elephants can
identify the elephant in the room be
blunt and get something out of the way
from the beginning which is we are not
researchers and we are not academics and
I know that there can be this Infamous
divide between the academics and the
program people I know the academics look
at us and say gosh like they're a bunch
of liars and because we do we
misrepresent your data all the time we
don't do it on purpose but we're so
focused on what's the so what what's the
spicy sexy takeaway what's the you know
the Twitter the 160 character
way to boil down a lot of research so we
do it it's not intentional but I know
we're working on it likewise we look at
academics and we think gosh their
PowerPoints are so ugly and for some
reason like we think that's important
and care about that so I know this
tension exists but if you're willing to
put it aside um for the next hour or so
are we because the reality is I know
that we need each other
um you all are out there identifying
problems identifying root causes coming
up with Solutions assessing what's
working assessing what's not working
um and then we take all of that and put
it in beautiful PowerPoint so really the
role you know we're working together and
and hopefully you'll see that we aim to
do a little more than that which we will
talk about today the work that we're
doing in advocacy and policy change in
helping enable implementation
um of new programs and ideas that
originate from data science and research
um so today we're are going to share a
little bit about panorama group and our
organization and then we are going to
highlight a couple specific examples of
projects that we do and our Reflections
on data science and what it means for
our work so I will kick us off with an
overview on Panorama group
um so
Panorama group we are a platform for
social change and what does that mean it
means essentially we don't specialize in
one specific topic area or functional
area but rather we specialize in making
change happen doing whatever it takes
the idea being that true social change
often comes by working together working
across entities across sectors across
topic areas and no one organization or
functional area can do it alone so what
we do at Panorama is to mobilize change
makers to work together and we aim to
equip social movements with the tools
needed to drive impact so as Jack
mentioned we have three different
organizations within the Panorama family
Panorama Global which is a social impact
nonprofit Panorama strategy a social
purpose consultancy which is where I sit
and then we have a new entity Panorama
action which is able to log be in
pursuit of social impact goals
this next slide shows a sampling of the
many different things that we do and the
different hats that we wear within
Panorama so we provide behind the scenes
Operational Support for emerging
non-profits we've run collaborative
funds where multiple donors can pool
resources to support a social cause that
they care about we deploy funds to
grantees we've launched coalitions we've
served as secretariats we provide
consulting services and the list can go
on and through that we've worked on a
variety of projects in different topic
areas our work stands both domestic work
and Global work the topics we tackle
range from public health gender Equity
climate Justice adolescent mental health
and more and working across all these
areas allows us to take learnings from
one issue area and apply them elsewhere
it also gives us exposure and experience
partnering with a range of Partners
ranging from academics philanthropist
ngos governments Etc and through all
that we've learned a lot about what it
takes to achieve change
so for the next bit we're gonna kind of
Deep dive and share more about two of
our programs one is the pandemic Action
Network we'll hear from Autumn and Darcy
and then Jen will talk to us about the
covid-19 action fund for Africa and then
I'll come back and share some
Reflections on what we've learned from
our Consulting work
um so with that autumn over to you
thanks so much Julia
um hi everyone uh it's my pleasure to
provide a little bit of context and
introduction on what pandemic Action
Network is and and what we do
um and how we translate
um Data Insights Research into actual
action and progress when it comes to
pandemic prevention preparedness and
response so I'm going to give a little
bit of context and turn it over to my
colleague Darcy and then wrap it up with
a little bit before we turn it over to
John
next slide please
so what is pandemic Action Network and
what is our role um essentially early uh
in covid the the DNA for pandemic Action
Network started far before that but a
group came together understanding based
on experience from previous outbreaks
namely Ebola in West Africa in 2014 and
2015. that in order to actually create
change in order to accelerate the
response to covid and to ensure that the
lessons from the covid-19 pandemic
actually translate into to real change
and better preparedness and Improvement
in the future
um that we needed advocacy in the mix so
pandemic Action Network really came
together and coalesced around an
advocacy Network to to bring Advocates
into this space to translate
recommendations reports Research into
tangible action because what often
happens in a pandemic is there's a
moment of Crisis and and there's a lot
of action around the crisis and then as
we're seeing right now uh people and
leaders collectively move on and there
will be a lot of research on the table a
lot of reports a lot of landscape
analyzes pointing to next time we should
do this differently or Lessons Learned
but there is a difference between
lessons documented and Lessons Learned
and so pandemic action Network's role is
to really be that connective tissue and
translate the recommendations into real
action next slide
oh
um it looks like
there we go
um so just to put a finer point on it
our mission as a network is to drive
Collective action uh to end the covid
crisis for everyone around the world and
ensure that the world is better prepared
to respond to outbreaks when and where
they happen and to prevent the next
pandemic
and the way that we do that our theory
of change essentially is that we need a
lot of different folks in the tent in
order to tackle these enormous
challenges so we believe that if we have
a diversity of stakeholders working
together that we can create advocacy
pressure to compel political leaders and
policy makers to act that means that the
network is incredibly diverse we are not
just a network of ngos or a network of
uh philanthropists funders or private
sector or academian research but we
bring all of those those powers and
perspectives to bear and and do that at
a global level at Regional levels and at
National levels
next slide please
with that our approach is is really a
partner approach we're actually a pretty
small and mighty team that has grown up
since uh we started this work in April
of 2020. we started out with about 25
Partners around the world we've now
grown to over 350 Partners across
sectors and across regions who are
actively participating and lending the
strength of their organizational
leadership their voice their strategy to
this fight to ensure that we're better
equipped at every level to prevent a
crisis like covet from happening again
but also ensuring that we're better
prepared in the future of when outbreaks
do occur and then all of that is powered
by our our Tiny But Mighty team which is
also spread out across the globe we now
have 18 people in nine different
countries in order to power this network
next slide
foreign
just gives you an idea of the vast
diversity of our Network this by all
means is not all of our 350 Partners it
would become just illegible at that
point but we're starting to get there
even with jamming all of these logos on
a single side but you can see the
diversity of uh those who who make up
the network from the private sector uh
businesses like like 3M Johnson and
Johnson we also have um
significant Public Public Health
agencies such as the Africa CDC that are
actively involved uh ngos and Advocates
at virtually every level
um that are a part of the network
day-to-day backside
and the way that we come together are
through various levers of action
um so we are essentially a policy and
advocacy network but in order to really
Drive pointed policy change when it
comes to you may have heard in the news
this week talking about the pandemic
afford or there's a number of
international Health regulations that
are up for review and reform
um or issues related to vaccine equity
in order to do that we really have to
drive Coalition building and convenience
around specific moments we also have to
actively engage influencers and key
opinion leaders in order to put pressure
on political leaders to act and all of
that is supported by very strategic
Communications and at Key moments
campaigns in order to ensure that these
priorities continue to stay at the top
of the the agenda
um this is increasingly more difficult
in the current context next slide
so overall our our strategic program of
work at this point in time it's really
evolved but in the beginning of course
we were focused on you know emergency
response to covid and what was necessary
from that perspective we have since
evolved our approaches we're really
looking at pandemic prevention and
preparedness and focus more on ecosystem
reforms on ensuring that there's there's
money for all of the things that need to
happen to strengthen Health Systems the
proper governance and accountability is
in place and all of this is supported by
a network model we want to ensure moving
forward that we don't have this huge gap
in advocacy when it comes to these
critically important issues but that
there's there's capacity building and
that is sustained over time
next slide
so just a little bit of context as we
continue the conversation today in terms
of like where we're at on the map and
I've alluded to some of this already but
we're in a very different place than we
were
three years ago we're now entering year
four of this pandemic we just marked the
third anniversary of uh the Declaration
by who of kovid as a global Health
Emergency so Public Health Emergency of
international concern
um at that time all of our Focus was was
on the pandemic the whole world was
watching
that's no longer the case we're in this
moment of what we're calling poly crisis
where there are so many different crises
that are that are on the map from
Ukraine to energy crisis debt crisis
food crisis
um it is
very distracting for political leaders
and and yet all of these things are
connected and compounded by the
persistent pandemic
um there's also a real lack of
coordinated and dedicated Global
Leadership to these issues pandemics
have really fallen down on the agenda
and our role is to ensure that does not
happen
um and we're really a forced to counter
this cycle of pandemic fatigue and and
cycle of neglect that really persists in
this space because the work is not done
yet
um and if we're not in the mix and not
being relentless about it uh there is
really a gap
because we know that health systems are
stretched at basically we're we're at a
Breaking Point around the world so many
things have fallen by the wayside
because of the focus on covid in the
pandemic there's stuffy shortages
there's a decrease in routine
immunization globally and there's the
need to address those issues well at the
same time ensuring that we're addressing
the persistent pandemic
as as we also look for it in terms of
of communications and the context around
all of this we're seeing the
real increase in anti-science and
disinformation rhetoric a lot of
distrust of Public Health authorities
um specifically in the United States
we're really seeing a risk of
disinvestment in this area safely when
we need
challenges are great
um and the work of this network is
incredibly important it needs to be
next slide
all right after that I'm going to turn
it over to Darcy right thank you so much
Autumn hi everybody I'm Darcy from evoke
kind which partnered uh with Panorama
back in March of 2020 to co-found the
pandemic Action Network and have the
great honor of staying on as a
Communications partner and as leadership
on the behavior change Communications
work group so I get the privilege of
talking to you about the work group but
also how we actually use and talk about
data science in this group so go head on
over to the next slide
when the when the the crisis hit when
the pandemic hit we really wanted to
pull together folks to talk about what
we could do now to help influence the
behaviors that needed to change to
prevent the spread of covid so we
brought these folks together into a work
group our mission was really around a
specific behavior we chose masking as
the the behavior that we could really
Drive consensus and Leadership on
um but what that practice gave us was
the structure of a monthly meeting of
bringing these disparate groups together
um as Autumn had said across like
Academia media Communications ngos
Public Health Etc
um and be a force a collaborative Force
to make decisions
um to share information to share
learnings um to set an agenda of what
needed to be done and figure out is
somebody covering it and can we help
that person and now we are in this
wonderful almost sort of routine of
getting back together every month and
having about one to three experts either
from within the work group or invited
guests to come share what they're
working on what their research is and
some of these the presentations that
stick with me the most are the ones that
are really rooted in that data science
and that are data-driven solutions for
disease prevention so I'm going to share
just a couple of those presentations
with you now but really an open
invitation
um to come learn more about what
pandemic Action Network is doing
specifically in the behavior change
Communications work group all right so
over to the next one
so one of our partners
um that came and gave us a presentation
early on actually came with an idea not
a fun finished product and the idea was
within the United States we were
starting already to see these partisan
divides around vaccination intention
um and how could we actually understand
more about what's going on in that space
and then use the best of data to inform
a solution
um so even though under the Trump
Administration was the development of
the vaccine there was also sort of an
equal measures
distrust hesitancy that was often
identity based and so uh we helped the a
coalition of of academics develop actual
messaging and materials for a ad that
was aired on through a purchase on
YouTube in specific pro-trump counties
that put the vaccine in the best
possible light and the they did a
large-scale randomized control trial
with it to assess whether this counter
stereotypical messaging and partisan
cues could actually induce vaccination
and what they learned and saw in those
results was indeed the counties that
were served at this particular ad showed
higher vaccination rates versus matching
counties that did not show the ad
so I know you're all saying okay that's
great I love seeing numbers but I love
seeing ads even more so Julia if
technology will comply is this a part
where you can switch over to the ad
itself and don't forget to share sound
Donald Trump is urging all Americans to
receive the covid-19 vaccine I would I
would recommend it and I would recommend
it to a lot of people that don't want to
get it and a lot of those people voted
for me frankly about Trump and former
first lady Melania Trump did receive
their vaccines privately in January at
the White House
[Music]
thank you yeah
I just love to share that example
um because we we followed the full Arc
of that progress right there was the
data to show the need that we all
responded to we helped identify where
some of the potential spokespeople could
be what were some of the uh messages
that were seeming to work with this
audience and in fact it was another
presentation from our work group that
had that data about that line your
vaccine is waiting for you that had come
from previous flu research that showed
impact that they were able to use as the
call to action at the end and then of
course they had the data to verify and
validate the results of
um the the whole entire project so
you'll see the reference at the bottom
if you want to look at the publication
so that was just one example moving now
across the Atlantic Ocean
um we were able also to hear from the UK
government on their approach and also
how they use data as a platform to
absolutely track every step of the way
where response was happening to various
stimuli in terms of messaging access to
um covet prevention measures whether it
be masking later on vaccination stay at
home Etc and they went through bit by
bit with our work group to go through
all the dashboards that they had
established and also how they use the
mechanisms within the UK government to
be able to quickly respond to any sort
of miscommunication misinformation that
was out there and ensure that different
stakeholders within the community were
serving as key Messengers
um and through the the measurements that
they had they were able to actually
track how many people stayed at home
you'll see in the data here almost 5.9
million 3.6 for million uh social
distance as a direct result of their
Communications and then they were able
to model how many infections were
presented prevented and what I think is
stunning that they were able with a
certain amount of confidence say that
through these particular strategies
between 22 and 27 000 lives were saved
which is stunning now
this is not a setting where pandemic
Action Network did this work but through
that collaborative and uh networked
approach a much wider range of ngos
non-profits other governments had
opportunity to learn from this and be in
touch with these so that they were able
to follow along
um and make sure they had that benefit
of that learning
so my final example is a a little bit
about past and future so we've been
partnering with the Mercury project
which is
um a call for basically research and
projects globally to actually use data
to understand and to come up with
data-driven solutions to improve
acceptance of vaccination and to dispel
misinformation and disinformation about
vaccination so they have come and
presented to us a number of times
including when they were doing their
first call for a cohort uh for what they
were funding and through pandemic Action
Network and other partners we're able to
find projects all over the globe that
are actually tackling this issue who are
currently in the field right now so at
our very next meeting which is on
February 16th we're going to learn from
the Mercury project how that first
cohort is going they're going to present
a new framework for research percent
they are using across these projects and
they are also going to announce and this
is what I really wanted to stress for
this group a new call for proposals for
the next cohort of projects so as you
are going through this program and
thinking what how can I get involved
what would be connected to this if you
have an intervention designed to
increase demand for vaccinations
consistent with national priorities and
that could be not just coveted
vaccination but childhood HPV polio
measles Etc this could be an opportunity
for additional funding so you'll see the
link there for how to get more
information about that
so without further Ado I'm going to turn
it back over to Autumn to tell us what's
next for pandemic Action Network
thanks Darcy
um well what's next for pandemic Action
Network is is a much bigger conversation
but one of the things that we wanted to
leave you with is is a little bit of a
forward-looking you know just thought
starter in terms of uh potential areas
for research and inquiry and as we look
at addressing secondary side effects of
covid-19 I mean look there are many uh
their Public Health social economic
political challenges related to Long
covid mental health education deferred
Healthcare
um the real failure of political leaders
to act or disinvest precisely when we
need to invest as I was speaking about
earlier the the growing attitude of
anti-science or dismissiveness
there are actually so many side of
scenery effects of covert that we
actually don't even know yet however we
wanted to leave you with two thought
starters first is a trend that we're
seeing in terms of growing distrust in
immunizations and this is not limited to
covid
um although covid-19
um anti-vax attitudes increasing has
potentially impacted what we're seeing
across the board
um there was a recent study by the
Kaiser Family Foundation you can see
some of the headlines on the right right
here in terms of growing vaccine
hesitancy fueling measles chickenpox
Resurgence in the U.S opposition to
school vaccine mandates
um from that recent study it was
determined and it was clear that more
than a third of parents now say that
they should have the right to not
vaccinate their children
um for measles mumps and rubella this is
an issue based on recent data that is
also clearly partisan uh in terms of 44
percent of adults who either identify as
Republican or republican leaning saying
that they should have the opportunity
and the choice to opt out this is a jump
up from 20 in a pre-pandemic poll this
is very significant and has the
potential to really
have an impact on public health and
Health Systems in the United States so
that's one area to get you all thinking
another area is is more squarely in our
wheelhouse and if there are areas of
inquiry around this area we really want
to talk to you and this is around the
failure to act on the impact of the
pandemic
we know that the kova 19 pandemic has
basically affected us all in one way or
another some more than others of course
um yeah but it is in the double digits
in terms of uh those who have been
personally impacted by losing a loved
one like we we feel these impacts quite
personally and yet the rhetoric at the
political level is disconnected from
that reality
um and in recent polls uh from National
polls in advance of the last election
the the midterm elections it actually
showed that like covid-19 was like the
least priority for people and yet the
priorities politically were around the
economy and inflation all things that
are actually squarely tied to the
pandemic and so we have this disconnect
between individual and personal
experience and constituencies and and
political leadership and areas of
investment men in a recent report from
the International Federation of the Red
Cross and red present societies that
they defined the pandemic as the biggest
disaster in living memory
um more than any earthquake drought
hurricane in history has claimed as many
lives so we're at a time where we really
need political leaders to act with
urgency in response to this crisis but
we're not seeing that and what will it
take to actually move a shifted
narrative and a shift in action
um and you know just as a Corollary
when 9 11 happened in the United States
there was a commission in Congress in
actual clear actions and policy changes
we're not seeing the same level of
action and on the contrary a lot of
politicization and that's specifically
in the US but we're seeing those Trends
across the board so two areas to
consider for future inquiry uh with that
I'll pass it over to my colleague
Jennifer
thank you so much Autumn and so as I
start I want to mention briefly that
just prior to joining Panorama I was in
university development for 10 years and
over that period of time I had the
privilege of supporting Engineers data
scientists and public health
professionals so I'm um I have a deep
appreciation for this lab and the work
that you all do
um so thrilled to be able to be here
um starting in 2022 I had the privilege
of working on two major Cova game team
response projects uh Grant making
initiative fund and supportive mental
health and well-being of hypoc and lgbtq
Adolescence and this project that I'm
about to share with you where we got to
go deep on global health challenges
under the age of pandemic Action Network
so as you may be able to guess from this
quote
I'm about to have ask you to come back
with me to March 2020.
what was starting to happen then there
was a global Scramble for PPE among even
the world's wealthiest countries we
discovered that most of the PPE was
being manufactured in just a small
number of areas shipping had slowed down
and here in the U.S and across around
the world routine Healthcare had paused
next slide please
so for those of you who are not familiar
community health workers are sometimes
called the invisible kajra
but they are the first line of defense
of prevention and treatment for hundreds
of millions of people around the world
including here in the U.S
so as the pandemic is starting to happen
what do we know
in most countries
um where that are heavily reliant on
community health workers as part of
their Health Systems they are not
formally part of the health system so
they are not counted as part of Health
worker accounts meaning that we are not
including them in projections for PPE
need
I think the thing that we all know very
deeply right now is that Frontline
health workers need PPE to work both for
their own safety and so that they are
prevented from becoming vectors of
disease infection themselves so
um this was flagged early on by the
community of of organizations that
support Community Health work the first
recorded death from covid-19 in Sierra
Leone was a community health worker the
longest tenured Community Health worker
in the country
and then this critical piece of
information that is the last statement
on the slide sometimes during times of
Crisis it's this the stoppage of
Essential Health Services it actually
leads to more so all the more reason for
attention
next slide please
for those of us who work in global
Health there was an obvious solution
someone needed to ensure that community
health workers had PPE and we were going
to need to use private funding to make
it happen
um and there was going to need to be a
mechanism to make it happen so next
slide
so
this life or death challenge
brought together more than 2 20 non-gov
governmental organizations in 18
ministries of Health
with five lead organizations and Julia
if you'll click please
um here is where I betray my age
um for those of you who might remember
Voltron or the ThunderCats or the Power
Rangers you'll get the idea a group of
organizations a number of which
collaborate regularly and several of
which are already members of pandemic
Action Network formed an ad hoc group
to take on key pieces of work in a
radically collaborative way to figure
out how to solve this problem
um it helps that several of us as I
mentioned have were collaborating
already
and really what informed this is that
we've been working very long term in
spaces of advocacy to understand how
does the health system work what are the
challenges and who needs to be engaged
in this effort
if we have to create our own mechanism
so next slide
what did we do
we created an end-to-end mechanism to
make this happen from needs estimation
fundraising sourcing all the way down to
Last Mile
and why did we think this would work
we had long-standing relationships with
donors who support community health
workers in disaster relief there's our
private funding we have the ability to
move relatively relatively quickly
thanks to relationships with
organizations and ministries of Health
we had been doing ongoing work to ensure
that the emergency effort could
potentially influence global Health
financing mechanisms
and we were going to take a pooled
procurement approach which meant that
this collection of otherwise of low and
middle-income countries who otherwise
would have no way of competing in the
global marketplace with countries like
the U.S could become competitive because
they were sourcing across countries
so next
I'm going to start here by highlighting
a few different elements and um I'm very
aware that as we think about this this
is small data but in a small data that
sits on top of really big data as you
can imagine but in ways that is messy
and spread out over countries
so what if you think back to what I said
earlier what do you do when there isn't
a formal count of community health
workers will you go to the organizations
that support community health workers
and you Source the information that way
so we worked with 20 plus organizations
to pool the information that they had to
create account and that count then
enabled us to have a marker against
which we could apply the best
information we had available in April
2020 to project what the actual need
would be in terms of supply and then if
you go to the next slide
what it was going to cost to supply
community health workers for a year I
want to pause here and say 100 million
dollars is a lot of money
And yet when you think about 100 million
dollars in terms of 400 million people
who rely on these Services it's not very
much
and at the same time we also knew that
in trying to do a rapid response it
wasn't very likely that we were going to
be able to raise 100 million dollars but
we were ambitious and it was part of an
effort to message that in the grand
scheme of global financing it wasn't a
lot of money to be able to protect the
health workers who are serving 400
million people
if you go to the next slide please
this is where it gets interesting
um
we had uh four elements in this process
that were constantly in flux imagine the
sliders on these bars Moving Day by Day
the best analogy that I had to explain
this when I was talking to donors it's
like using GPS if you're the kind of
person who's willing to take the
recommended side route it's in constant
calculation all the time so if somebody
would tell me on a given day I need you
to be able to tell me how far is my two
million dollars gonna go
now I would have to say well it depends
on what Supply we have and with the
shipping and the ability of these
countries to accept the funding or
accept the supply
we were constantly calculating to
maximize donor dollars
feed and assure quality
so from here I want to highlight a few
things on the next slide
from left to right it's very hard to see
this but
um bye we got very lucky that we were
under the leadership for this component
of direct relief which is one of the
country's largest humanitarian or relief
organizations they had great
relationships so on behalf of the
countries we were working with they were
able to negotiate an incredibly good
rate at a time when the market was at
Peak to enable us to supply countries in
sub-Saharan Africa
um they were also managing all of that
list of items in the early stages of
this we had to make sure the supply in a
very rapidly changing environment would
be able to meet our own quality
assurance as well as the requirements of
individual countries
if you look at the middle section
um again remember that shipping had
slowed down so for the first one and a
half rounds of procurement we benefited
from the fact that the world food
program working with some donors had set
it up a free to use of transport and
because we were working at such a large
scale we were able to leverage free
flights for quite a bit of this work
meaning that our donor dollars were
going more towards bias and then in that
third
oh no even as you think about
um
once the sorry even as we were procuring
we were needing to think about whether
countries were even going to be able to
accept the supply so memorandums of
understanding needed to be in place of
each country and for some countries they
hadn't ever had to manage Supply at this
scale they didn't always have the
technical capacity or experience to
handle it so we had to do some training
in Uganda for example this was the
largest shipment of supplies they had
ever received and we had to break it up
into two pieces in order to enable them
to do it and then um just moving quickly
to the next slide
how are we ensuring these get to
community health workers if you've
worked in global Health you know that
sometimes this is the hardest The Last
Mile I've highlighted two of the more
extreme examples of ways that we got
supplies to community health workers on
the left-hand side these visors went to
a polio campaign in the Democratic
Republic of Congo that we weren't sure
was going to happen but did because the
supplies were provided 8 500 community
health workers went door to door to
ensure the campaign happened
and in the next slide you'll see
we did some pretty intensive tracking
where possible we use the Ministry of
Health Supply chains to do this but
otherwise we were using relying on NGO
expertise to get this done
in the next slide
our impact so we started our deliveries
in August 2020
and by January of 2022 this is what we
had achieved
I want to highlight this was shocking to
us in 2020 we were the fifth largest
procurement mechanism for PPE
but the most important thing was Julia
if you'll click again
this was the impact
we were able to achieve as much as
possible
to prevent a stoppage in routine health
services at the community level
so what did we learn
there's some highlights here
um
and one of the things that I really one
of the things that was very exciting for
us is that is this last point where in
some instances we were able to use this
as a leverage moment to finally get
community health workers recognized as
part of the health system
most critically for us in the middle and
end stages of this the last thing that
we did as part of this project when we
wrapped up in January was that we took
all of the Lessons Learned forward
through pandemic and pandemic Action
Network to provide information to the
global Health Community about gaps that
we were anticipating that would prevent
things from moving forward improvements
that could be made
um and key areas that needed to be
addressed
um we're hoping that this effort in
addition to having a tremendous impact
on delivery of health services will also
serve to continue to reinforce the need
for pandemic preparedness and the
inclusion of community health workers
um I'll stop here there's a variety of
different information that we provided
in the slides that were shared with you
earlier and we would be happy to answer
any questions
great thanks Jen and to the whole team
I'm gonna spend just five minutes
wrapping us up and then we will do some
q a
um so as I mentioned at the beginning I
work um a Paramus strategy which is the
Consulting arm of the company we realize
that from all these different programs
that we've been involved in we've
learned a lot and we now want to support
other people who are engaging in social
change Ambitions to to share our
learnings and help them enhance their
social impact so let's hear a little bit
about us and then some of our learnings
in terms of data science
so our focus is on we help clients with
strategy development strategic
Communications stakeholder engagement
and advocacy
we partner with a number of different
types of organizations from William
philanthropy to academic institutions
multilaterals government agencies we
partner with pharmaceutical companies
and other basically we are willing to
engage with anyone who has the goal of
having social impact
um and then what we've learned through
that work is you know the world has
changed so much since coven and things
that we thought we used to know about
global Health about other areas we no
longer know we need new data we need to
understand the secondary effects of
covid-19 and how it has touched every
other element of our world
um most importantly what we've learned
is that the pathway from evidence to
public health impact is rarely
straightforward
um ideally we would you know once we
have the data to understand what is the
problem what are the solutions like that
would be it however in reality that
that's typically only step one
instead what we've found is we are
constantly relying on a number of
different levers and going back and
forth between them to in order to reach
that impact so for example we're helping
our partners figure out what advocacy is
needed what are the different platforms
to disseminate your message and the
advocacy material and what is the
framing and the Strategic messaging that
will resonate with key decision makers
we're looking at you know what is the
state of the world right now what are
the topics people care about what will
help politicians get reelected
understanding different people's
interests and priorities and then
helping to tell a story in that context
we also realized that often what's
required is policy change and we look
across Global Regional National local
policies informal recommendations from
trusted advisors plays a big role as
well
um for example in my previous work I
worked in um spent a number of years in
Africa and Asia supporting governments
on the vaccine introductions and we
found that when we did field research a
number of countries had a rule that if
they're going to make a policy change
they need a one of their government
approved people on the research team
who's doing the field research so
understanding like what does it take for
decision makers to act on the evidence
that they have
um also with in terms of changes needed
and solutions to problems with often
much bigger than the one thing that
you're trying to change but there's a
surrounding ecosystem and infrastructure
needed to enable that change so for
example sustainable financing
um changes in global Health often has
impact on the health Workforce and the
HR needs their supply chain factors to
take into account as Jen spoke to some
systems need to be reconfigured
um Behavior change as Darcy spoke to
these themes are all relevant almost
every issue that we're tackling
likewise we um Acro was for change to
happen as we talked about the beginning
there's a role for a lot of different
stakeholders to play so there needs to
be strong coordination to move the group
forward towards shared goals there also
needs to be strong leadership and social
movements and then not just funding for
the implementation piece but funding for
all this other work there needs to be
funding to you know prop up the advocacy
movement or to take the time to do the
necessary steps to go through policy
change to fund the research to have the
answers
um and we spend a lot of time playing
between these webs and bouncing back and
forth and making progress and then
having to shift in another Direction
and I am really excited to be joining
those of you who are going to The
Innovation lab in June I'm really
excited that I'll be spending that week
with you
um and be helping to think through for
the different research projects you're
interested in you know what is the
surrounding policy context what does the
advocacy space look like you know what
are non-traditional research Outlets
research funding Outlets to consider so
excited to spend that time with you all
um for now if you just closing kind of
high level thoughts
I think um a few key takeaways so I
think one is when designing and
conducting research I hope that you know
you see it's important to know what does
come next and what are all the
contextual factors at play and knowing
that early can help in the design and
planning around research I also think
it's important to strengthen the
collaboration and communication across
that Academic Program divide I think
there's a lot more that we could you
know advance and I think we could work
with a lot of efficiency if we were in
better touch across those communities
so those are a couple of Reflections
from us really enjoyed getting to to
spend this time with you and for now
we'll open it turn it back to Jack who
will
um field any questions oh thank you so
much Julia thank you Jennifer Darcy and
Autumn this was uh really a fantastic uh
presentation from the Panorama team and
you guys have done so much stuff one of
the things which I think was just
Dawning on me as you guys were speaking
and it was kind of when autumn was
presenting some of her her comments
about you know really we we witnessed
something with the pandemic that I don't
think we've probably not seen in in My
Generation
Um up until then and certainly many of
of us have experienced the same thing
was science in real time right science
was happening and it was in this really
compressed time frame and so you know
pity poor Anthony fauci you know kind of
taking it on the chin for us all as we
like watch this process go on on where
people didn't really realize what
science kind of involves which is a lot
of Wrong Turns a lot of you know getting
new information incorporating it and
changing it and you talked about the
loss of public trust and I was kind of
curious about how Nimble our
organizations like yours to be able to
help smooth that process so that people
can like take action but at the same
time realize that stuff's happening
changing every day how can your
organizations help with that to educate
people and policy makers about those
things Autumn maybe you can comment on
that yeah I'll start and then I suspect
that Darcy has some some thoughts as
well
um
as a network you know we work through
our partners and so there are different
ways that we've activated particularly
around clarifying message and uh
responding to miss and disinformation
um because it is all around and it has
just felt exponential
um and
so through our partners
um we have been able to leverage
resources when it comes to key messaging
around you know XYZ and setting the
facts straight which has been incredibly
important for the general population
audience particularly early on in the
pandemic because
Public Health Communications is quite
challenging again Darcy can do a Ted
Talk on this in her sleep
um but there's so many things that we
don't know and when information changes
and when when the information evolves
there's a lot of like lack of
understanding of like well last week you
said this and now you're saying this and
as a network it was really important to
leverage from across our Network the
best information and resources and
messaging so that we collectively could
all be on the same page
and that's important as things have
continued and now that we're squarely on
the the back side of the vaccine era of
the pandemic there's a whole other set
of myths and disinformation and
um and there's there's the tip of this
beer but there's the back of the spear
in terms of responding to that the tip
of the spear is really like where people
receive their information but from an
advocacy perspective our network has
worked with uh Partners such as uh the
center for countering digital hate which
is based in the UK but works globally to
really Advocate to
platforms themselves in terms of how
they
um
they provide a space for Miss and
disinformation to spread and we thought
very early on in covid where you were
seeing all sorts of things and then
there was a tampering down and a very
intentionality of like of not giving the
green light to any conspiracy theory and
rumor we're actually seeing a dangerous
backsliding on that now with recent
changes and ownership of different
platforms and whatnot and it and it puts
the onus even more on the platforms and
and on our community to continue to
Advocate to to protect folks and and
really ensure that the facts are
surfacing in the media we also have
organizations that are part of our
Network that are actually actively
focused on using the latest data and
insights and and guidance to educate the
media themselves and journalists because
all of a sudden you had every journalist
in the world became a public health
reporter and they never ever covered
public health and that's quite a
challenge and so there's a media really
literacy piece of all of this I'll stop
there and turn it over to Darcy yeah I
just want to say with science and then
the communication of science and health
messages it really is a strength and
number situation and one of the benefits
I think that panda a role that pandemic
Action Network could play early on and
continuing on is making sure that all of
the key players who are both in the
space of learning but then also
communicating out we're talking to each
other I mean I saw it through multiple
phases in the masking messaging of how
we were getting out because obviously
the science that we had in terms of the
benefits of mass as prevention from
covid spread is a question that was
constantly evolving and what kind of
mass what level of protection does it
just protect you know if you're the
person who's sick does it protect the
people around you or do you get some
measure if you're the healthy person of
protection these were questions that did
not have good answers for a long time
but what we were able to do frankly is
through our various Partners make sure
we were asking those questions and
getting the best answers that we had and
then the rest of the network was singing
off the same sheet of paper and then as
there was new information that we were
also prompting folks across the network
for for new information and I have as we
were preparing for
um we launched uh World mask week in the
summer of 2020 to really get these
Partners on board to be all singing in
concert on this message and I I honestly
remember some conversations with various
Folks at CDC and other places where it
was evident that even among our network
not everybody had sort of the latest and
greatest and so to make sure that
everybody was having what is the the the
best science at that moment to be able
to sing off of that sheet of paper and
that's particularly as things like
better masks came on the market that
were more readily available that they
were less worrying about
um uh not being available for health
care providers we were able to act
quickly on that but I do believe that
the next you know we need to make clear
sort of from the outset about Science
Education health education that change
will happen so that we can prepare folks
for it that we will always give the best
of what we know now and that that will
be evolved and then they need to come
along with us for that Journey
fantastic Jennifer uh you had really
gave a fantastic example of just a
logistical challenge of trying to one
figure out how to get money for
something how to then go and like scale
it appropriately and deliver I mean the
logistical challenges were really
evident there and anytime somebody does
a Power Rangers name drop I'd like you
got my attention I wanted to ask you
what role could data scientists help
play in helping to make sure that the
the mathematics that went behind the
distribution and the logistics of all
that how could that how could that be
brought to bear to help streamline and
make that process more efficient
um so here I'm going to apologize in
advance if I accidentally offend anyone
um and this comes from
um having worked with some having had
the privilege of working with some data
scientists I think there's a few things
one
when you work at scale with data you
have
um at least as I understand it there's
some wonderful opportunity in there for
you to see patterns that are not evident
to those of us who are looking who are
working at it day by day who are
inputting just a small set of those and
so
there's a little bit of a superpower in
there and helping us understand that you
can see something coming or you see
something that is if we Zoom back out
from it what is the opportunity there
there's we're trying to fix small things
in big systems that are complicated is
there a bigger fix that could happen
because of that I think the other thing
is that I have
um worked with people who are both very
um excited to or also very opposed to
the idea that the kinds of tools that
are needed in the moment when you're
trying to be nimble when you're working
with smaller sets of data when the data
is really messy
um sometimes what we call in this at the
field level a tool is so rudimentary to
people who are thinking about really
complex data and
um but you also have no idea how huge an
impact a small tool that is easy for you
to build can have I think
um we were I mean I'm just going to
admit that we were managing all of this
information when I showed you those
slider bars that was a series of Excel
spreadsheets it maybe didn't need to be
more complicated than that but when we
think about planning as that scales when
we think about how those tools translate
back to a community what could be built
that is simple to use that accommodates
the data and has the ability to scale so
um if anytime you look at something
you're like well that's so easy maybe
think about being thinking maybe think
about I can take a few minutes and
create that and then maybe to learn
something from the data that's going
into it
and that's fantastic
um I think we're very close to the end
of our time here I wanted to certainly
thank Julia for organizing everybody and
thank Autumn and Darcy and Jennifer for
providing kind of examples of things
that are going on with uh with with the
team here and the various things that
Panorama group has going on both in the
U.S and around the world to really help
us get our thoughts together to build
the network we need to be able to know
who we can talk to to help make sure
that people are getting the right
information to be able to affect policy
to affect change uh both uh policy wise
and behavioral uh we're I was very
excited to hear about the Mercury
project as well and so I look forward to
kind of poking around in there a little
bit as well but thank you for bringing
that to our attention and thank you guys
um for for sharing this with us this is
really wonderful work and I'm sure that
everybody is our participants are going
to be very excited to talk to Julia here
in June in person to to find out more
details so thank you again and thanks to
everyone who joined us and who's
watching